bonjour je m'appelle léa et je suis né à
beyrouth
quelques mois plus tard à leur retour en
france
mes parents ont planté un cèdre dans
leur jardin
très vite j'ai tissé un lien avec cet
arbre déjà parce que j'aimais bien m'en
servir comme point de repère pour mes
course à trottinettes
ensuite parce que c'était le meilleur
allié dans mes batailles de boules de
neige avec mon frère
tous les ans un peu avant noël on aimait
bien décorée et puis avec mon père on
avait même construit une petite cabane
en bois qu'on avait accroché à l'une de
ses branches pour que les oiseaux du
jardin est un refuge
finalement le cèdre et moi nous sommes
devenus amis
nous sommes devenus amis parce que l'on
se ressemblent et oui je sais ce que
vous vous dites mais je vous assure
qu'on se ressemble
ressemble parce que comme lui j'ai mes
racines au liban et montrons qui grandit
en france
alors en grandissant je me suis toujours
sentie différente de vous à moi je ne
sais pas très bien pourquoi j'étais
différente même si j'ai quelques
hypothèses déjà j'ai grandi entre
plusieurs civilisations
je suis né à beyrouth on a vécu une
partie de notre vie aux états unis à
boston puis on est arrivé en france
je crois qu'il ya aussi le fait qu' on
ne me parlait pas la même langue à la
maison qu'à l'école et avec mes amis et
puis sans doute aussi le fait que mes
parents travailler beaucoup pour
construire leur carrière
mais je crois que le jour où j'ai mis un
mot sur cette différence
c'était en classe de cp
la grand mère de ma meilleure amie
clémence était venu la chercher à la
sortie de l'école et à ce moment là je
me suis rendu compte que mes grands
parents ne pourraient jamais venir me
chercher parce qu'il habitait à quatre
heures et demie d'avion
aussi grandir à 4000 kilomètres du lieu
où vous êtes né savoir le sentiment
d'être pas là pour les fêtes
trop loin pour les drames toujours entre
deux toujours dans un paradoxe constants
le tout premier l'exposé que j'ai eu à
faire de ma scolarité c'était
raconte-nous d'où tu viens
certains dans ma classe on parlait de
vélizy d'autres ont parlé de bruxelles
et moi j'étais super fier de parler de
paix route
j'étais heureuse de leur faire goûter
les desserts libanais qu'on avait acheté
avec ma mère
et en même temps quand
tres m'a demandé de dire une phrase en
arabe devant toute la classe
criant n'est sorti parce que j'avais
honte
alors je dois vous avouer quelque chose
j'avais honte de parler arabe pas du
tout parce que j'avais honte de mon pays
l'avion de parler arabe parce que je
savais très bien que je ne parlais pas
aussi bien que les vrais libanaise c'est
vrai j'étais l'ami libanaise en france
est la cousine française quand
j'arrivais au liban
j'étais jamais vraiment 100% lundi
jamais vraiment 100% l'autre un tout
petit peu de l'un est un tout petit peu
de l'autre
c'est pas évident de se construire entre
deux pays c'est encore moins évident de
construire son identité de femme entre
deux civilisations la conception de la
famille radicalement différente
entre deux civilisations l'ordinaire de
lune l extraordinaire de l'autre
pour vous donner un exemple le jour où
j'ai quitté le domicile familial pour la
toute première fois mes amis en france
trouvez ça normal
quand ma famille au liban mes grands
parents en particulier bien que très
aisément ont vu dans mon déménagement un
acte d'insurrection
alors je crois qu'une explication à ça
c'est que le temps au liban n'est pas le
même que celui en france
quand vous êtes né dans un pays qui a
souvent été détruits et que vous vivez
loin de ce pays
il ya là-bas l'urgence de reconstruire
et ici la culpabilité d'être trop loin
pour aider la culpabilité d'être protégé
d'être en sécurité
le 4 août dernier quand le port de
beyrouth a explosé je me rappelle m'être
réveillée le lendemain matin on ne
comprenant pas comment ma france pouvait
continuer à tourner
quand mon liban s'était arrêté
alors oui c'est vrai ces dernières
années j'ai eu du mal à trouver ma place
j'ai eu 11 parfois j'ai culpabilisé
souvent
hiré toujours et c'est dans ce contexte
là que j'ai construit ma vie d'adulte
bien sûr bien plus tard je me suis rendu
compte qu'il y avait plein de points
positifs
on a fui le liban en 2006 mon père m'a
dit de ne pas me mon père m'a dit de ne
pas m'inquiéter pour ce pays parce que
c'était l'un des seuls pays au monde où
les habitants sortait pour reconstruire
avant même que la guerre soit terminé
beyrouth m'a appris à ne jamais rien
lâcher beyrouth m'a appris à toujours me
battre a toujours y croire
en octobre 2014 quand ma grand mère aïda
est décédé très vite des suites d'une
leucémie foudroyante
j'avais 14 ans et j'étais en classe de
seconde
j'avais très envie de m'engager pour
faire un peu quand même
et apporter ma pierre à l'édifice dans
la lutte contre le cancer donc j'ai
contacté des associations en leur disant
bonjour je m'appelle les âges et 14 ans
j'aimerais beaucoup vous aider qu'est-ce
que je peux faire
et à chaque fois on me répondait que
j'étais trop jeune que je n'étais pas à
ma place
il fallait que je revienne plus tard
quand ma grand mère était à l'hôpital je
me suis rendu compte qu'il y avait plein
de jeunes de mon âge il y avait la même
maladie qu'elle est qu'ils étaient à
l'hôpital toute la journée
entourés d'adultes est loin de leur
environnement naturel qui est d'être
entouré de jeunes
j'ai donc décidé de créer l'association
aïda qui porte le prénom de ma grand
mère et qui permet à des jeunes et en
particulier à des jeunes de moins de 18
ans de s'engager dans la lutte contre le
cancer
alors je vais pas vous vendre du rêve
c'est pas parce qu'on a une association
etc on a 14 ans que jour au lendemain on
est pris au sérieux pas du tout on a
toqué à la porte des hôpitaux on a toqué
à la porte de certains labos de
recherche
on a toqué à la porte d'association et à
chaque fois c'était le même discours
revenez plus tard revenez demain
votre place vous êtes trop jeune
on n'a rien lâché et aujourd'hui aida
mobilise près de 80 mille jeunes en
france
elle engage près de 2500 bénévoles dont
80% à moins de 18 ans et à soutient
chaque année près de deux mille deux
cents patients dans plus de 50 hôpitaux
en france
finalement c'est ça l'héritage franco
libanais
c'est cette capacité à penser grand à
rêver grand amont l'entrée en sixième
mes parents m'ont offert un petit carnet
sur lequel il y avait écrit le futur
appartient à ceux qui croient en leurs
rêves prendre entre paris et beyrouth
m'a appris à penser grand à penser sans
aucune limite
sans aucune frontière à sentir que
j'étais citoyenne d'un seul et même
monde
et que finalement le monde est tellement
grand qu'il n'y a pas une place mais
qu'il ya plein de place
alors oui c'est vrai j'ai grandi loin
d'une partie de ma famille quand vous
grandissez loin de ceux que vous aimez
vous vous rendez compte à quel point ils
sont nécessaires j'ai aussi grandi dans
une famille de femmes dans une famille
dominé par les femmes je dirais même
c'est pas toujours
evidon mais ça a plein de points
positifs pour vous donner un exemple
très récent
quand vous ne savez pas quoi mettre pour
une conférence vous n'avez qu'à passer
un coup de fil et pouf vous êtes habillé
j'en profite donc merci maman à toutes
mes tantes à mes cousines pour la tenue
et vous l'aurez remarqué j'ai cité mon
père et ma mère je suis donc une
parfaite petite fille libanaise
sérieusement c'est sept chats
maternelle qu'on essaie d'insuffler chez
aïda
très récemment une bénévole des débuts
m'a remercié pour deux raisons
première c'est qaïda a été la première
structure à lui faire confiance
a considéré qu'elle était plus qu'une
situation familiale compliquée qu'elle
valait plus que des mauvaises notes à
l'école
da au lycée a été son refuge
la deuxième raison c'est qu'elle s'est
rendue compte que aujourd'hui il ya une
part d' aïda en elle ce qu'elle ne sait
pas c'est qu'il ya aussi une part d'elle
en aïda
ida était devenue sa deuxième maison sa
famille
ce que l'éloignement vous apprends aussi
c'est la nécessité de chérir l'instant
présent
je suis encore là la voix de ma
grand-mère dans la tête qui me demandait
quand est-ce qu'on veut la voir au liban
répondait alors là ça va être compliqué
mais peut-être plus tard alors peut-être
à noël plus tard ou plus tard cet été
jusqu'au jour où vous vous rendez compte
que plus tard
c'est trop tard
ce qu'il ya d'essentiel
dans aïda ce qui est essentiel quand
vous travaillez à l'hôpital ce que vous
apprenez
c'est qu'il faut vivre l'instant présent
et qu'il faut vivre la vie comme en état
d'urgence
alors je m'appelle les a je suis né à
beyrouth
quelques mois plus tard à leur retour en
france mes parents ont planté un cèdre
dans leur jardin
alors aujourd'hui il a bien grandi il
mesure plus de 25 mètres de haut et moi
aussi j'ai grandi
ce qui est génial c'est que grâce à nos
racines au liban
grâce à notre tron qui s'est élevé nos
en france on a tous les deux trouvé
notre place
mon rôle aujourd'hui c'est d'aider
d'autres jeunes à trouver la leur les
racines bien ancrées
le tronc bien solide et puis les
branches dans les étoiles
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]